jean marie fabre il est président des
vignerons indépendants de france jean
marie fabre bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors pour commencer
peut-être racontez nous avec les
dernières jouent les comment est-ce que
ça s'est passé comment est ce que vous
vous êtes organisés pour pour sauver vos
vignoble et est ce que vous avez pu
sauver une partie de vos vignoble lourds
n'ont malheureusement je crois que nous
cette année à l'épisode climatique de
gelée et massif l'a quasiment épargné
aucun bassin viticole français et la
nature de cet épisode de sa puissance à
des températures négatives ont
malheureusement annulé la quasi-totalité
des outils techniques permettant parfois
de réduire l'impact de ces jolies alors
le premier ministre a pris des mesures
d'urgence à on parle d'un milliard
d'euros pour l'agriculture sinistrée par
le gel vous l'avez rencontré vous un ct
samedi le premier ministre est ce que
ces mesures elles vont suffire selon
nous allons d'abord je pense que pour le
coup l'état a répondu rapidement
huit jours après les épisodes de gel des
dispositifs sont sur la table au produit
et correspondent me semble-t-il à tout
un panel de mesures que nous souhaitions
remis sur la table pour répondre à
l'urgence urgence morale dans le silo
sciences économiques que vont traverser
votre entreprise année dans les semaines
dans les mois et années qui arrivent
notamment avec les allégements de
charges et la capacité à générer plus de
facilités en matière de trésorerie
puisque notre secteur suivie depuis déjà
quatorze mois les effectifs du retrait
marqué de la pandémie avec une séquence
économique où nous connaissons donc
aujourd'hui les mesures qui sont sur la
table en matière d'urgence nous
paraissent être à définir maintenant à
des réunions soldats pour définir les
modalités d'application mais plutôt dans
la droite ligne de ce que nous portions
en matière de dispositifs
vous parlez d'une urgence morale pour
qu'on comprenne bien un épisode
climatique comme celui qu'on a vécu
c'est quoi les conséquences
très concrètement pour un viticulteur ça
veut dire qu'il a plus rien du jour au
lendemain
alors tout va dépendre bien évidemment
de la nature de l' épisode de gel qui
l'a suivi on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
80% des vignobles français sont impactés
les parcelles vont parfois de 30 à 100 %
donc une parcelle qui a été touchée à
100% il ne reste plus rien sa capacité à
produire c'est peut-être 10 15 20 % sur
une année normale donc ça veut dire 80 %
de perte ham en fêtes et donc 80% du
chiffre d'affaires - dans les mois qui
arrivent dans l'année qui arrive donc
effectivement la difficulté de cet
épisode de jeunes viennent aussi du fait
encore une fois qu'il arrive à un moment
où certaines étaient déjà fragilisées en
matière de résilience par rapport aux 14
mois de quasi non commercialisation qui
viennent de passer avec la fermeture des
chr avec les difficultés à l'export avec
l'annulation de tous les salons grand
public et professionnels et les
capacités à nos consommateurs parfois à
traverser notre pays pour venir
directement se fournir d'amour dans nos
domaines
donc effectivement la détresse morale
aujourd'hui était importante plus
importante qu'à l'accoutumée lors des
épisodes climatiques parce qu'elle y est
se cumuler à des difficultés économiques
qui ont déjà maintenant quelques mois
est ce que on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
il aurait désespéré pour la filière
viticole
comment est ce que vous le vivez comment
est-ce que vivo vos confrères également
alors ils le vivent comme un épisode
climatiques c'est à dire qu on est
toujours soumis à ces aléas on n'est pas
dupe sur ce point là mais effectivement
on a le sentiment que les choses
s'acharne à la fois de mon côté la
pandémie et ses conséquences des
difficultés que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui l'épisode climatique vient
se rajouter à cet état d'esprit donc il
fait parfois baisser les bras et éviter
beaucoup les annonces qui viennent
d'être faites qui vont permettre
d'alléger les trésoreries sont déjà un
signe positif le moral commence déjà à
être différent mais il va falloir que ça
se traduise par une efficacité concrètes
rapide adaptée à chaque secteur
et puis il va falloir aussi que nous
abordions pour les semaines qui arrivent
j'allais dire le moyen terme ce capacité
à à différer nos encours bancaires de
base notamment aux prêts garantis l'état
que nous avons consentis pendant la
pandémie et qui de facto ne pourront pas
être remboursées là dans les matières il
dans les années qui arrivent parce que
nous allons être amputé de 40 50 60
voire plus de notre chiffre d'affaires
donc toutes ces mesures là vont devons
être bien calibré bien définis bien
argumentée pour ensuite être bien bien
traduites dans la mise en oeuvre au
quotidien pour que nos entreprises est
aux capacités à être résiliente et donc
à se pérenniser et à maintenir le rôle
qui est le leur je vous rappelle que la
filière viticole c'est 7,5 me d'emploi
quasiment sur 66 départements français
c'est 60 55 à 60 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et que cet épisode
climatique viennent nous enserrant père
au bas mot 15 à des millions certains de
vos collègues réclame l'organisation
d'un grand grenelle de l'agriculture
serait une bonne chose alors je pense
qu'il faut toujours réagir avec beaucoup
de froideur par rapport à ces épisodes
je pense qu'il ya du court terme il ya
du moyen terme et il ya du long terme
je pense que le court terme c'est
l'urgence d'urgence on l'a dit moral
mais aussi l'urgence économique
il faut donner les moyens à nos
entreprises d'y voir plus clair d'être à
capacité de maintenir les salariés qui
sont les leurs de maintenir leurs parts
de marché de maintenir leur activité et
d'être encore là dans six des huit ou
dix mois ensuite il va y avoir le moyen
terme et le grenelle peut faire partie
de ces réflexions qu'il faut savoir
poser est regardée avec beaucoup plus de
recul
moi je pense qu'il ya aussi tout le
sujet de la résilience et qui doit
passer par une produits assurantiels qui
aujourd'hui on le voit s'il est
suffisamment veut utiliser
c'est pas parce que les gens sont
irresponsables c'est parce qu'il est
souvent inadapté ou inopérants en
fonction des réseaux distribution et des
charges fixes de nos entreprises donc il
ya une véritable la véritable enjeu
celui de reposer ensemble la nécessité
d'un outil assurantiel qui répondent
dans les années qui arrivent aux enjeux
de résilience
mais aussi de pérennité et on voit bien
que la récurrence des aléas climatiques
qui certainement traduit le changement
climatique va nous amener à devoir avoir
une produits assurantiels prêt
spécifique réadapter et très efficace
on entend parler d'une éventuelle
réouverture des restaurants alors on
parle de la mi-mai à rien et rien n'est
encore sûr est ce que c'est une
perspective que vous attendez
impatiemment ça représente
un marché important celui de la
restauration pour vous oui c'est une
date que l'on suit avec énormément
énormément d'intérêt bien évidemment
pour les vignerons indépendants en
france qui commercialisent leur
production en direct alors à la fois
l'export à la fois sur des bien
de chr la c1 chercher de plus de 25% de
notre commercialisation sur le marché
français mais ça veut dire aussi la ch r
ce sont tous nos distributeurs qui
achètent nos produits pour les mettre en
marché dans les pays voisins à l'union
européenne au grand export et pour le
compte duquel aujourd'hui là aussi la
restauration est temps de fermer le chr
est enfermé nous avons subi un impact
direct avec des baisses de
commercialisation l'arrêt sur ces
circuits la de commercialisation depuis
plusieurs mois donc oui il est important
que la restauration puis se réouvrir en
france en europe et dans l'ensemble des
pays
nos produits sont concernés merci
beaucoup jean marie fabre d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur la
naissance je le rappelle vous êtes
président des vignerons indépendants de
france